if you could take one guy to an island
with you and you knew you'd be safe
because he was the best man it was going
to keep you happy if it was between me
and your father who would you take daddy
I think you're wrong about that loosely
what happened to my brother
so that's the agenda understand which
part are you having trouble I can't be
the Guardian
well your brother provided for your
nephew Sookie I think the idea was that
you would relocate relocate to Whitwell
if he AG it was my impression that you'd
spent a lot of time here nice yeah I'm
just the back of me nobody can
appreciate what you've been through and
if you really feel you can't take this
on me that's your right when we going to
the orphanage shut up in the car
can't obey your eyes until you unlock
the door what did you decide you can
always stay with us if he wants to come
up weekends do you want to be his
guardian well he doesn't really my god
he's already got a houseful trying to
lose teachers at this point hello hello
Lee I just want to call and say I'm
sorry yeah how's Patrick two isn't
really open up with me you actually have
sex with these girls
strictly basement business where's that
mean it means I'm working on it
you don't want to be my guardian that's
fine with me like that it's just it was
justice all my friends are here I got
two girlfriends and I'm in a band you're
a janitor and Quincy what the hell do
you care where you live
I've said a lot of terrible things to
you my heart was broken my nose is
broken too no you don't understand
there's nothing that true
there's something wrong with me don't
recall your friends what do you want man
I'm not gonna bother you I just sit
there until you calm down all right I'm
calm enough but you please just go away
you know
come on pull it out you know thanks most
of the rest of us will never know
that's gotta weigh heavy on a young man
shoulders
it's really